Paris was the second stop of the day on
Alexis tsipras is European charm
offensive tsipras is looking to ease
crippling austerity measures in his
country and restructure its debt in a
joint news conference after the meeting
French president Francois Hollande
stressed the importance of working
together to solve Greece's problems the
premiere the first principle is that of
solidarity we're in the same monetary
zone so we have the same interests the
same issues and the same obligations
objective the second principle is that
of responsibility beautiful we are all
responsible for our currency some glass
more subdued Monday earlier Tuesday
tsipras was in Brussels to present his
demands to the presidents of three EU
institutions two topics dominated the
discussion first the troika the auditors
from the ECB the IMF and the EU are
hated in greece athens is tired of being
monitored the new government wants to
decide its own reforms and then there's
the debt Cyprus's election campaign
focused on getting a debt write-off now
he avoids the term preferring debt swap
his idea bonds tied to growth should
ease the burden European Commission head
jean-claude Juncker has indicated an
openness to dialogue so tsipras can hope
for some concessions we thought like
maybe we'll have to adapt a few policies
maybe we won't change all of them just
because of an election result that some
like and some don't ozaukee deeply what
an outright debt reduction for Greece is
out of the question for Brussels but
tsipras said he's optimistic about
finding a solution after meeting with
European Parliament head Martin shoulds
I know very well that the history of
European Union is a history of
disagreements but in the end of the day
of compromises of agreements and we have
the willingness to work in this
direction an EU summit next week might
produce
deal on the debt issue a compromise is
needed fast the current extension to
Greece's aid package runs out at the end
of February